you are so real
it's incredible may I
it's amazing
so up there are you like sing right now
it's a kind of sleep a human experience
the survival of the human body of life
that's really Central to the mission
which began on British television before
switching to Netflix has just returned
for its first new season in four years
and ahead of the release we sat down
this week with Charlie Brooker in London
the creative mind behind the mirror
I saw a thing that had sort of gone
viral where somebody had said Black
Mirror was written by one stoned British
dude who just says things like what if
your mum ran on batteries and that's not
a million miles away from the truth
Shirley Brooker has been living in Black
Mirror world for 12 years now
but because the show is so unusual you
never know when a new season will come
out
or how many episodes it will feature I'm
always I think healthily terrified in
the in the run-up to the show actually
coming out because you spend a lot of
time sort of in your own head to start
with when you're writing it and then you
take that Freight out on the viewers
hopefully
the show has lots of different flavors
across a series and and this time around
I've sort of pushed that to its extremes
I think that's Keith holligan sir
he murdered his wife oh it was
manslaughter the title of the show comes
from the reflective surface of a
computer or TV screen when it's turned
off
a powered down device becomes a Black
Mirror
is there a floor for how dark you'll go
uh possibly not or if there is I haven't
quite found it yet Brooker who we met at
the British Film Institute in London
started his career as a Cartoonist
before writing and presenting television
criticism then eventually switched to
television creation congratulations on
saying mirror because a lot of Americans
call it mirror Black Mirror has become
his crowning achievement a modern day
Twilight Zone Please Mr Chambers Eat
we wouldn't want you to lose weight
that was definitely a huge inspiration
that it was this sort of mix of sci-fi
and horror and ideas and um
sometimes Darkly playful sometimes
incredibly cruel
[Music]
a show like Black Mirror is you want to
give people what they're there for but
equally you want to keep it surprising
one of the things it turns out people
turn up to Black mirrorathore is to be
left with no sense of hope so
occasionally it's quite fun to deliver
on that why have you done this to me uh
well uh actually you did this to you
real you is paying for this each episode
of Black Mirror is a standalone story
with different actors that's Salma Hayek
uh she even has your hair in addition to
Hayek the First new season since 2019
includes Josh Hartnett Aaron Paul and
Moore you know I don't read this crap
viciously satirized social media and
Technology
but the show born in the comedy
department at its old home on Britain's
Channel 4 continues to evolve most of
the new chapters have a retro feel the
exploiting a sense of nostalgia
while tackling Timeless topics of
surveillance and voyeurism I have to say
that actually legally
the streamberry corporation can do this
you savage the streaming services and at
least a couple of these episodes
including a Netflix replica
you're on Netflix am I biting the head
in the face yeah I think it's more a
gentle a playful nibble it's not gentle
they can't do this to me there are
really so many ways for me to tell you
that they absolutely can you still write
every single episode uh so one of them
this time around was co-written with
Bishop K Ali but generally yeah I tend
to I think because it's quite an
idiosyncratic show either that or I'm
just
a lunatic which both those statements
yeah those both could be true statements
couldn't they yeah
sometimes it's two days to write an
episode sometimes it's months quite
often the ideas are knocking around for
quite a long time until there's a moment
where they seem right or there'll be
elements of it where there were elements
of the Joni's awful story that I was
thinking about for a long time and then
the Stars will align and you suddenly
sort of a missing piece of it falls into
place and you write it quite quickly
Bergerac
all detective shop your folks were
seriously into it it is an odd process
and I find it again I think sometimes
you need to think you need to sort of
shake things up a bit for yourself
usually ideas come to me when I'm in
idle conversation with people or I'm
watching a TV show with my wife or
something like that maybe the most
jarring and addictive elements of every
Black Mirror episode is the end
which we're not sure anyone ever
is able to predict what the f is this
how the f is this if people are left
railing in astonishment and or horror
then we're that's mission accomplished
we we always used to say it's like a uh
it's an assortment box of chocolates you
don't know what filling you're going to
get but it's going to be dark chocolate
on the outside that's the sort of
psychological thread that's running
through the whole thing
I like I like dark chocolate who doesn't
I mean again the great thing about Black
Mirror because it's an anthology you can
pick up any episode from any season and
just watch it and you know he talks
about a sense of hopelessness and people
say how terrified they are watching it
sometimes I don't get that as much I
just it makes you think you're
entertained you're also scared a little
bit but I just it's just so creative
that he's I like the moment where he was
like when you maybe I'm a little crazy
you know writing his own episodes and it
was he started thinking about it like
hmm
I mean maybe a little bit of both right
people ask everybody's asking during the
piece about favorite episodes so I'm
just going to do this really quickly I
would say for those Black Mirror fans
San Junipero I think was a favorite of
mine
entire history of you and from this new
season the last episode in the new
season is called demon 79. so you've
been you've been watching for some time
seems like go Jeff watch